welcome to this video this is coverage
for round 10 the final round of the sink
filled cup 2013 that was held in San
Luis you insane let's look at the final
round games yeah the tournament of
course has already decided koala had
such a brilliant event that he had it in
the back of all ready for two rolls so
it's just about final standing maybe
some prize money let's see what happened
in this round I'm starting with Nakamura
against the vasila graph both players
near the bottom of the table especially
like a Miura had a really terrible event
so let's see what happened in the last
round we get an ID off md outs favorite
defense against you for neuro camera
goes for age 3 this funny looking for
nowadays is one of the main lines
against the night off intending a g4
push it all depends a bit on blacks
response of course but very often wide
wants to go g4 and one black is doing
now is a very modern approach that
simply prevents a g4 I think this kind
of approach would have been pretty much
unthinkable 20-30 years ago but nowadays
it looks kind of normal that you want to
prevent the space gainer them only
apparent drawback of this move is that
Bishop g5 is a pin and white will
probably manage to get this traded on f6
so that he has at the end three three
pieces too yep to control with d5 and
black only to defend it this is a
typical device in the Sicilian here with
the weekend square with the white very
often enjoying an advantage but it's a
very much depends on how the pieces are
positioned one problem is and we will
see this later especially here that
white has three
pieces for this square but that's just
what square so you have a ton of pieces
that are in a way in yeah superfluous
the knight on c3 for example is just a
backup piece 45 but it's not doing very
much on its own and if black in this
position type avoids trades on the d5
square he is normally totally okay what
he shouldn't do for example after a move
like played in the game here black
shouldn't play something like 97 this is
a positional mistake that is in some
White's life considerably yeah the
strand of this kind of trade it's simply
good for wide as now those two pieces
are really doing something here and the
knight on c3 is gone like should do
something active with this knight on c6
and not trade and what he did was to
jump to deform it's also very logical
that after nitey to he did not take on e
2 but on b3 here the same thing applies
for the tree as it does for the trade
only to that black changes of a squared
a piece that also wants to go to d5 but
he gets the total bishop pair in
compensation so this should be very much
okay for black he gains the space on the
queenside and after a form he has a very
useful reply before it's very nice using
this pin so wyd cannot take with the
night and should he decide to take with
the Queen black is getting to see too
and yeah this is certainly okay for
black c3 was played and we get to a very
comparable structure now but the rook is
still on c8 yeah White has a two against
one here on the queenside and if
everything would would run Bell for
white you'd be able to to push
this and get a passer but black is not
very cooperative here just place a five
to make sure this is not so easily done
the whole position at first I thought it
may be worth something for white because
he's got this ideas on the d6 pawn with
night to be five maybe doubling with
Rupert III those kind of ideas but if we
look at the game continuation the way it
went there was a little repetition here
but Nakamura is playing on the way it
went it all felt very logical like s
protecting the six from the side and it
is not really apparent how wide is going
to increases pressure here note that
there is simply no option for whites to
trade on the C file as the age six
bishop is doing only one thing but this
this is doing very well preventing the
this precise trade on the C file so wyd
really only has this is piling up on the
d6 bond and we see that white is putting
the utmost pressure there but it's
really not leading to much if we look at
this position how is wide ever going to
to win the pawn if he for example
retreats now black can simply play Queen
B eight and yeah put another defender on
the pawn white cannot take now because
of this funny reply when this look is
under fire and it really has nowhere to
go to without giving out the d6 night so
very strange setup yeah if rook takes we
have this kind of idea coming
where the night is in an awkward pin the
threat is Bishop e7 and it's very
difficult for wide to handle it looks
good at first but how do you continue
white can try something like that but
black is very active here this is a
weakness and especially if war is a
weakness we should be 3 as a move to
come some of those nights are very much
dependent on one another and it's not a
harmonious position yeah he played the
rooks III trying to exchange one pair of
brooks and we we got there but still it
all seems too who would pretty
comfortably for black yeah if now nighty
XD 6 like its am taking on d5 and has no
problems yeah it all seemed very very
young very very clean game Quincy 6 yeah
note that black after twin takes e4 also
is ok now white can't do something like
that iam but it's also going to end in
some sort of Perpetual check on one of
the Kings in the game we had quinsy 6
check capture and then g3 yeah they're
various ways now to to get to a to a
draw they went for check for this way of
check check it's now agree to it wrong
yeah I guess a very very clean game with
no mistakes by both sides so it just
happens they both play well and and it
ends in a draw the interesting
positional point of the game is really
here where black must avoid to trade the
trade as d 5 against c6 but should try
to get some useful role for its night on
deform like 94 text be 3s played in the
game ok the next move to look at is some
pile of Carlton and yeah what about
those two players yeah to pull off in
this event he started terribly with two
losses but then really really am yeah he
he pulled himself together and then
scored a couple of wins so the gaseous
he's not enthusiastic about his
performance I guess I mean it is it is
50% it's nothing super brilliant but I
guess considering that he started that
badly I think he's pretty much okay with
that and we had the world champion
Carlton yeah he had a had a bad start
really losing to kawana and the in the
first turn the sum game by he played
very aggressively after that he managed
to score 2 wins against my camera and
and Aronian yeah an endgame grind
against Aronian that he that he won done
nicely and yeah I really had a totally
off day I mean even worse than even
compared to his bad performance in the
tournament this was really a bad game um
gantu cousin was lucky to escape against
kawana in the second turn so not a
brilliant event but so we need to
consider that Carlton with his plus one
is playing a 2800 performance it's not
like you played like Watson ok let's
look at look and look at this game we
got the pertinent wall and in fact we
got the endgame to Palo allowed the
endgame can and yeah this is of course a
common battleground nowadays cards and
goes for one of the numerous lines with
King ATM and b6 yeah that's really a a
maze of lines Black has so many setups
97 Bishop e7 Bishop to d7 and b6 and age
6 and so on this is 11 beauty of this
line 44 black
he can play this set up and then vary
with a ton of setups that all are
playable in a way and it's very
difficult for y to find some some some
clear way forward also big advantages
that modern chess engines even very
up-to-date on great Hardware they have
trouble to to get some somewhere in
those positions let's see what the
parlor hyt played Bishop f4 and we are
Bishop b4 is played yeah this is some am
slightly uncommon way to play but it
looks very interesting to my eye because
yeah if it is a very well-known effect
that if Black gets to exchange his
Bishop his dark squared Bishop in the
structure he normally is very okay
because when he manages to exchange it
and especially against the night Bishop
against the bishop is far less
attractive but Bishop against Knight you
exchange a night which might help to
fight for the light squares on the King
side we see that this is a kind of a
light square blockade if you manage to
liquidate one of those nights very often
this play on the King side is is easier
for black to to establish this kind of
bind here that with later made maybe h5
that helps to prevent any g for F for
business yay exchanging this is
considerably favor considered favorable
normally and with bishop before he tries
that right away it's funny that after 94
now black has the move Bishop a6 and
yeah both bishops are suddenly very
active yahoo com to see one was now
plate I mean there is not really a great
square available this looks normal but
do you really want this I don't think so
this looks this is really unattractive
no I Dwight has really misplayed things
yeah he went to Roxy one and not really
Bishop b2 well it's funny
this night is simply attacked and you
cannot absolutely cannot allow a double
porn here which would have destroyer
structure totally so to pull off plate
92 and now black has this as mentioned
simple solution of trading on d to just
giving away the bishop but making sure
that he hasn't gotten this this
favorable peace distribution note that
the bishop on f form is always kind of a
set piece for white as it looks at this
e5 pawn and does not do anything active
so when I'd say that black already has
no problem here 94 was not played this
is a move designed to also maybe go to
e6 which can be a good square for the
night now to pile up late Bishop e3 and
checking this night and yeah the most
natural move and probably best move is
to retreat went to pile of plate and
Bishop f4 yeah if you already probably
get a sneaking suspicion here and in
Hecht and this is what happened they
shuffled two times and agreed to a draw
here yeah not not a great game for the
spectators but it is understandable
after this event of totally attend
rounds that there's some lack of energy
in the final round plus them you need to
look at if you look at both players
they're both known to be the absolute
fighters around ya cousin is very very
rarely playing such a game and the same
is true for to power off so we we
shouldn't be too critical about that
there are players who do that far far
far more often so it is an I guess okay
yet also it's not that easy to to really
amp we deviate from that you can but
it's not like it promises any player
very much don't forget that we already
have opposite colored bishops which
increase the drawing tendency enormously
so it's not like they had a super
full-blooded fight that they could have
continued it's a it's a rather boring
position that they didn't bother to to
play for a ton of move so I I really
understand that and we had fantastic
nine rounds before so I I don't really
am criticize him too much for that okay
so final game to look at for this round
the final round is our own young kawana
this is the duel between the former
world number two Aronian and the new
world number two Cara wanna who really
made the huge step forward with this
tournament he gained am I think that's
35 points I think at 35 points almost
yeah 35 and this means that he's now
almost 40 points ahead of aronia maybe
even even some some something 4046 maybe
it's a huge huge difference with this
big score yeah okay let's look at this
game we had a symmetrical English very
popular defense nowadays 293 or two to
see for why does really having a hard
time to get anything here and one reason
is that the line d 4 takes takes e6 has
proven to be very solid for black it's
very difficult for y to get anything
here and the most popular tribe in
recent years is a three but this is also
not promising why the tone black can
play / should be seven castles normal
moves it's it's really quite an okay
line for black so why players very often
try g3 and after that now black has a
choice but mostly they play d5 the idea
is that after C takes knight takes
Bishop g2 97 black one student set up
this reverse maroc see this is a line
that Kara wanna head on the board
earlier in the first round in fact
against a part of a one pretty
convincing game aronian is doing
something else he plays deform and this
is the line that I play as well so
I am I fully understand why aronian is
doing this because seat XD 95 is not the
position that i believe promises white
very much and in fact i personally don't
like it at all but Sir it's not that bad
i guess but i understand that white
wants to avoid it with d for you get a
more yeah a more more interesting play
in the center i think yeah what is the
idea one idea is that if black takes on
c4 which is not a good idea you have d5
and the night will need to lose time
black also can consider to take on d4
after that 94 is played and this is a
pretty good structure for white the only
thing that black can do here to try to
irritate white is to take and after that
we would get this kind of any game which
has been played a number of times by
back ramnik especially in the in the
Penguins mostly in the 90s early 2000s
when he had some knives in a nice games
with that it's a line that promises
white a very slight pool it's nothing
spectacular but something that you can
play for an advantage car one however
played e6 and this after C takes Knight
takes transposase to a line of the
samurai tirage Bishop g2 and now like
takes on d4 this is probably the best
line here black can also play Bishop e7
but this leads to entirely different
structures here white can decide to to
get to a iqp position after all mostly
then play this and yeah white is
probably very slightly better here see
takes is the moisture solid choice white
captures and now black takes on deform
ok B takes and now night XD form yeah
black is going for form for mass
exchanges here trying to reduce the
pressure
yeah now aronian goes for an interesting
move I personally play Queen D for you
if I reach its position which is nothing
that that you can head to enthusiastic
about but still it's a position where
you can try to do something based on the
fact that you have the better bishop
yeah black can play Bishop before here
or B should be six something like that
and it's a position that it's very very
solid for black it's nothing great or
anything but it's it's tough to lose
this position as black you can have good
chances for a draw however Aronian
played this dark you should be for check
he went king f1 this looks weird it's
certainly a playable line but I don't
really believe that this can be
something that white can play for an
advantage with simply with the rukon h1
how do you get your pieces coordinated
yeah what black does he loses some time
with this Bishop so why it has some
activity going home and now with h4 it
tries to make some sense of the off the
edge one look but you create very normal
move you want to probably play b6 and
Bishop e7 later we try of age six yeah H
takes a typical move you want to stop
the porn before it comes to h6 and might
be am very annoying for the for the
black king and to e46 we should be three
I think this all looks very logical if
you consider the general concept with
with King f1 white occupied the center
he pushed h4 h5 it looks very normal 'if
I've we are putting a stake in the
center what black does probably not want
to do is to allow something like a five
Queen g-form and white hairs pressure on
the on the kingside this why 'if I've
was played
yeah wyd now captured probably this says
this is a good decision white could also
try to just close it but it's not clear
to me that after a moment normal move
like that why it really has any plane
and yeah black is may be coming with f5
at some point and then you ask yourself
if your king really is in a good
situation on their phone so I think
erroneous move is fine thus capture and
f4 it pretty much by force leads to what
happens in the game chat got the Queen
trade Bishop g4 with the temple and now
be should to be two blacks got to active
bishops and white still has this rook
age one which is not contributing to the
game yeah why does quickly trying to to
change that and wants to get rid of the
the bishop on g4 as well yeah what are
blacks moves now yeah he cannot take
here there is a very long thick cover
from the rukon b5 and if you go Bishop
to f3 widest going Bishop g2 and this
didn't help very much he went oops sorry
he went with with the trade could have
gone to d1 to make things a little bit
more complicated but it does not really
change much check this is a very obvious
way to play like it is quick with his
rooks now and certainly has no problems
whatsoever rook b3 is a precise moved
him on to get rid of this a3 Bishop
which control it's important square here
yeah we got got to this position and
yeah you probably already suspect that
this game will end in a draw and in fact
this happened after a couple of more
moves here they agreed to draw in this
completely equal endgame yeah it is
really not much to do here I actually
have a different
actually have one more move our own yet
in my version of the game I had it
downloaded from the side okay then
somehow my version had had one more move
okay not a not a big deal at all yeah it
is simply an equal end game with nothing
to play for on on that level yeah um
this final round certainly wasn't the
most thrilling but in general we have
seen a really great event the number of
draws was very low I'm not one hundred
percent sure I didn't calculate this
properly but we were about fifty percent
during the tournament of decisive games
of course the last three rounds erm had
had many drawers we had and how many
drawers let's have a look we had eight
drawers out of nine games in the in the
final three rounds which certainly is
also due to the fact that this kind of
event it it takes its toll it's not like
you play this this kind of thing all the
time so it's a it's a matter of physical
fitness and stamina so at the end um
they they're more inclined to play a
draw however those drawers mostly were
interesting I mean the final round
really not that much but the other
drawers were very much fighting games
think of Caruana Nakamura last round or
cards in her own yen was fought to the
backing so we had drawers but we didn't
have uneventful drawers yeah them and of
course this tournament will be
remembered as probably the greatest
performance ever why can 1 i've played a
3080 performance if i'm not mistaken
which is really out of this world and i
think it firmly establishes something
that you already yeah could them could
suspect during this year that kiwanis
maybe the the main
tender to challenge cards in the future
for the world title he seems a bit more
yeah a bit more focused when it counts
I'm not quite sure how to put it but he
seems less intimidated by carlson than
many other players and he really has
beaten guard and quite a number of times
the overall score still okay for Magnus
but karen has at least been urging to
win games there are other players who
simply never win I mean look at Nakamura
yeah some great things to be expected
the next term very interesting event
simply as is coming up right now and
this is the big question if there is a
world championship match with guards nor
not do to em hit some yeah up to now and
refusal to to sign this contract for the
Sochi match if Carson is not playing we
will probably have a very awkward
situation because feeder will need to to
stage what championship mentioned this
sir if i'm not mistaken would be Anand
playing kayaking which really sounds a
bit ridiculous and as both players some
I mean an unqualified for the match and
he will play but it's really kind of
ridiculous to play World Championship
match without Magnus so it will be very
interesting to see what what happens in
the next couple of days it really must
be the next couple of days or maybe even
today September seventh because this
deadline has expired with the end of
this tournament and it doesn't look good
if what i read this is the correct
current at the correct description of
the of events so maybe we really am long
term won't have this match ok let's see
what happens there thanks for watching
this video and hope you I hope you
enjoyed the coverage thanks for watching